hey welcome desk IJ you know that show
where you guys ask me all these
questions and then I sort of answer them
but I actually spend most of my time
trying to figure out how I don't
actually answer your question at all if
that makes any sense even if you're
really that upset about me not answering
one of your questions just check out
this video it's a cute kitty saying no
no no no not while it eats something off
of the spoon by K Phi IJ Devi good
question if I could drink only one thing
for the rest of my life it would be this
but I don't know how to pronounce it no
Sarah I do not want a mustache and no I
actually do not have a mustache because
let me tell you how many comments I get
randomly on my video saying Jessie if
you a message hate this she doesn't even
know what I look like I have one it's
just the lighting green can I have a
high five if I could go into the past
and change anything what would I change
in Y I probably wouldn't change anything
am I going to watch the new season of
Jersey Shore no have you ever been to
the Jersey Shore no are you sure you
haven't been to the Jersey Shore yes
Twitter question hmm the iPhone five
years I'm not really sure what its
meaning your life but I really do hope
that it will be able to bring me
breakfast lunch and dinner and maybe
even drive in a car you guys ask me all
the time what I looked like when I was a
baby well here are some family photos of
you nesters
when am I gonna make a rap with Josh um
I'm not sure maybe she go ask him my
favorite character on True Blood is
Jessica she is by far the coolest
vampire I have ever really guess I
didn't meet her so I can say that she's
by far the coolest vampire ever if he
just made my alter ego or an eye her
alter ego I think that's more of a
question for her to answer I said that I
need preparation on the brother
preparation if you're gonna ask me some
questions
I just are you pissed about you just get
to the sea no shut this off just shut
this shut this off if a Christian Sydney
wants to know my take on cigarettes and
smoking I've actually never smoked
before and I never plan on smoking
because I kind of think it's pretty
disgusting so you know I'm not judging
you if you smoke that's okay that's your
choice but uh yeah it's not cool it's
really not so you probably shouldn't do
it have I ever used a telescope oh yes I
have used a telescope and let me tell
you what I saw with it oh my goodness it
looks just like yes my favorite thing
from Harris Teeter are the fries was
Ayyanar door was that cool in school
you guys decided nerd not a nerd
DJ Preston yes I am in fact nominated
for Teen Choice Award if you want to
vote for me please vote for me I'll be
posting a link in the underbar so click
it and uh yeah both thank you guys for
nominating me make us sweet and sassy
wants to never have any advice for
making YouTube videos my main advice is
just to start doing it because I'm
pretty sure most of the videos that
you're gonna post the first time I
posted with you on YouTube is probably
gonna be pretty awful here take a look
at the first video that I ever posted in
YouTube
in the last episode my question of the
video was what song do you currently
have stuck in your head
welllet's en bunny 37 has the song
t-pain buy you a drink
so I thought I would sing that for you
this episode's question for you guys is
if you could see anyone in any of my
videos doing something who would you
want to see in my video and what would
you want them to be doing cuz you never
know anything's possible
thank you guys for watching this episode
of ask AJ and I will see you guys soon
and stay tuned because I have a new fun
show coming up and I hope you guys like
it alright see you soon don't you to
subscribe and check out my last a
scheduled video here okay